foreign
none of those languages can speak to
each other
definitely
it's less members of the public and
staff welcome to this meeting for the
community well-being committee
uh we have and welcome to those who have
also joined us on the live stream
apologies we were running just a couple
of minutes behind time
we have apologies from councilors Boyle
pottinger and Stewart somebody'd like to
move that they are accepted council's
Dermody and sopa thank you put that all
in favor
aye against
carried one item in public forum Mr
Brian Rowe on behalf of the already
Sands users group Mr Right you want to
take a take a seat please
thank you for coming along this
afternoon uh you've got 10 minutes that
we allow for presentations in public
forum if you want to leave some time for
questions add up to that's up to you if
you want to use the entire 10 minutes
again that's up to you
a copy of the document you've supplied
have just been circulated to cancel us
but the time is yours thank you good
afternoon Mia and members of committee
the Priestess maps and diagrams had to
be read in conjunction with this address
I recently emailed Carolyn brain manager
of parks with the question was forestry
Zone 2 included in the tender document
c1175 forestry management of Sandy Point
the reply
the only forestry which occurs at any
point or can occur at Cindy Point
relates to the 2013 Sandy Point domain
management plan if there are any
suggestions to order this they will come
through in revisions of the management
plan
to early 2024
forestry Zone 2 is included in the Sandy
Point management plan on page 15 of the
Sandy Point domain management plan two
thousand sorry 2013.
the golf course would have to be renamed
is perhaps tracks and field
I began working more dogs around I
already Sands in August 2018.
soon after the course closed Council
maintained it for sit for a couple of
years and then there was a form of
Maintenance and that grass was cut for
bailage
since February 2020 I've been emailing
Pax about how the old course and tracks
have been degrading mainly because of
invasion by lupines
I was also emailed every counselor in
the mirror
Park's response is that it is a low-mo
area
there will only mow a basic track two
meters wide of approximately four
kilometers
I heard rumors that the council was
going to close the course down and use
it for forestry and carbon credits going
online I found the Sandy Point domain
management plan July 2013.
in March of this year I started up a
Facebook group I really send users
currently it has a reach of about 3 000
people
I recently conducted a poll within the
group
did you know that in 2022 ICC had
submissions open to the public regarding
the future of Reedy Sands and the whole
of Sandy Point domain for the next 30 to
50 years
responded in the negative
the only reporting the local media and
that I'm aware of of a master plan and
submissions to it was in staff on the
26th of December 2022 three months after
submissions to it it closed
in March of this year I walked around
much of the course with Carolyn Rayne
Carol also told me that dog she had
asked or Walkers whether they were happy
with the track
her pong indicated 100 acceptance
I created another pool with pole within
the users group 88 were not happy with
track only
I was advised to the master plan a new
management plan which be completed by
the end of 2012.
she suggested that submissions to the
master plan would be reopened to
stakeholders
we the already send user groups now
being a stakeholder in November of this
year
however in the documentation in let's
talk on the ICC website it says public
engagement on a preferred master plan
option a schedule for November
uses group submission would be that
Rudy Sands would be kept open for
multiple users in the nature of a golf
course that is with wide open areas of
land protected by forested areas and
clearly defined tracks
although multiple groups such as
orienteering harriers triathletes dog
walkers and recreational Walkers Army
police disc golf and schools use the
course
and surrounds there are opportunities
through organizations such as active
Southland and the disability Resource
Center to make it a recreational Hub and
greatly enhance the early Sands
experience
the main barrier is the lack of
Maintenance or a Samsung waffle
negligence particularly in reference to
Invasion plants such as lupine's broom
and gourse
the bulk of the lupins is contained
within Zone 2 Forestry
already a couple of the old Fairways are
choke with them
working with an expert in land
reclamation we've been looking at
clearing the lupines and other peace
plants at zero cost to the right part
the stumbling block is that within Zone
2 Parks will not allow
lupines to be cleared nor tracks
re-established it certainly doesn't make
any sense unless
this is stuff from March 2023 from an
interview with Carol and Rain by Michael
fellow referring to the management plan
although lupines are not present within
this plan treatment for the eradication
of lupines is best undertaken in
conjunction with a re-visitation plan
over the course of many years she said
thank you
it's wondrous
so
what is it you're looking for Brian
well
the persistent rumors out there that the
course is closing down
um I've asked whether volunteers could
um
fix the problems that are out there
mainly with the lupines we find a
contract a bit will do it
but he's not able to do it
he's been told he's not he's not allowed
to touch the lupines and he's not
allowed to touch the tracks which makes
it pretty much impossible for him to do
his job
uh we also
need to put our submissions in that
course be kept open is
in the nature of a golf course in other
words that it is wide open and there are
plenty of tricks
a couple of things I need to clarify
first of all we need to be careful about
rumors because
generally most of them are baseless
um the course closing the only closing
that's happened is the golf club I'm not
aware nor has there been any discussion
at the council table of the closure of
anything else particularly since it
seems to be a multi-use facility at the
moment
and I'm just I'm a little bit of
clarification about when you say the
nature of a golf course because I think
the nature of a golf course as opposed
to any other Reserve is very different
um
having played golf a long time ago but
you know there's a there's a much finer
degree of of mowing are you talking
about a more accessible space or or
something almost carpet-like no just
accessible space okay
thank you questions counselors Tom then
rear
brainer I mean I take the dog doing
there so I know what you're talking
about
um I mean do you see any obviously if
there's no Revenue then all of the cost
of what you're describing would fall and
rate peers do you see any upper do you
see any opportunity for
um reason Revenue in that area
raising enough
Revenue
from the area to keep it maintained yes
that's what we're looking at I mean
obviously Bay hook means if you came up
with anything yet or I mean you love
those obviously the opportunity make a
submission later but have you actually
came up with some ideas already yeah
which keeps it open
let's moan every year or two or three
times a year depending on what the
weather's like
um
the act of doing it keeps the loopings
down
so and at some point I'm searching it
and at some point
you'll be able to do about your budget
that shows
how it's a balanced budget this is what
the village is worth this is what it
would cost to well that's up to the
contractor and he assures me that
there'll be no cost
you can make enough money out of it as
long as he's given as much of the old
course that he's able to
rear then mayor Clark Mr ro2 in
try to seek some clarification from your
um delivery to us today so from my
understanding the South and golf club
closed this Links golf course which was
proposed to be the best 20th
um Link Golf Course in southern
hemisphere in 2018. yeah so since then
am I right in second clarification the
expectation has been that it's Fallen
back on the council to maintain that
land but not to the expectation of an
actual golf course as we have now in
other areas in invercargill
from what I understand 2000
2018-2020 it was maintained by
Council in the form of a golf course
from then there was gone through sit
component to that yeah from then there
was contractors went in and took bailage
but they only took pilots from the
fairways they didn't actually
manage any of the lupines so when they
stopped
um doing biology element the lupus have
just started taking over so really your
requests if I'm understanding right is
that you want the lupines the broom and
the ghost control better so that it can
be used more as a multi-sport correct
outdoor area correct Angie think that by
providing Bay ledge or doing Ballers
that that will help remove that yeah the
contractors has said that he would
remove the
the um
the course in the broom and the lupines
because it gives them more area more
area he's got obviously more Revenue he
can make
and
more area that's
available that's better off for everyone
and the erraticians users are proposing
for this to be used as a um to become an
official dog park as well no what we are
proposing that at some point
um
maybe groups like active Southland and
disability people or and the multi-use
people get together and decide what and
how they're going to use them okay
thank you
before I go to make like just a reminder
that um the area is part of that Lomo
pilot which Council asked for and so
there was a reduction of the mowing
services on that site
as Brian has said but on Mr I suggestion
actually we've had a contractor in touch
with parks and they're negotiating a
bailage and mulching contract which is
nearing completion at the moment so
right okay
yeah thank you chair
um yeah the Ron I'll pay your email as
well
um I've passed on to Caroline Raines the
issue of
um
the 91 that weren't aware so I'll pass
that on that um
certainly from my expectations that's
not a good way to engage on a long-term
plan to have very few people engaging
back with it sorry oh well I passed on
to her that I thought that
um 91 of a users Group which is was your
odotara group that spread out not being
aware that was a long-term plan coming
forward and having some chance input is
not a good way for us to engage it needs
to be wider than that
um and I want the dog there just about
every day as well okay and I do
um
and it seems to me that the um
the bailage issue predates our decision
to not most frequently I think the
lupines and the other things were a
problem before we made that decision
recently to to mow this I think it's
always it's been a creeping problem
that's been coming out just leading to a
question
well all right
um so as Ron Riley still
um some of the tracks down the middle no
no he stopped doing it
okay
well thank you Evelyn
um
three YouTubers throughout um the issue
of bailage
in the cost recovery to enable these
things to uh
these activities to continue to happen
at no cost to the people who use the
facility so you're expecting the bailage
to pay for yep
right
my understanding with return for bailage
mean is that at some point you have to
resaw because otherwise the quality of
what you take off there is not they're
not going to pay you anything for it
it's just taking it off for the sake of
clearing it off
um
who do you perceive would pay for that
um the contractor
would patiently so
to enable additional failage yeah
let's do his it's to his advantage
slightly interesting how do you perceive
that if that happened their level of
activity on that on those
um
Open Spaces would increase
yeah
um well it's it's increased
I would say
hundreds of percent more than it was
before because it was in the newspaper
and I used to go at the end I used to be
out there on my own now I can hardly get
a car park during the week and I don't
go out in the weekends or just can't
I just can't get in there and
there's more and more people using not
only for dog walking but running in that
and Perry as I have their annual meat
out there I presume if it's still viable
the course survival I mean
um the schools will have their Triathlon
event that they have had for a number of
years
those sort of things
thank you thank you
um look I'm aware that we've gone over
time for the public forum it's a light
agenda but I will take one more Grant
yeah yeah just that's probably more a
question for the
um Steve or one of the team have we
costed out what the cost to maintain
would be to a standard that's greater
than what it is at the moment so I would
just we've taken a low-mo sort of narrow
strip approach we went to a a wider
management contract here much would that
be you know through the chair now we
haven't at this point we haven't con
costed that I think that will come
through once we've completed the master
plan and then go into the reserve
management planning process because once
we understand the use of that space then
we can come back with detailed costings
of yeah what the options are through the
master plan and what the option is that
we prepare to go to through the
management plan process itself yeah
which will happen later this year and I
think the all of our stakeholder groups
will get the chance to have a say at
that point again yeah because I think
the proposal around having a contractor
do it would become commercial
commercially driven and all of a sudden
you'd have a develop Paddock out there
that's cut three or four times and you'd
have other issues so I'm not sure that
areas cut out to be a bad Edge Paddock
in my experience so if I can follow on
from that Steve
which point does this become a matter
which we consider because we've got the
master plan which is due out later this
year and we heard this morning that the
lidar information is in so we will hit
that Target
and then we go into the Sandy Point
management plan
at which stage are we likely to be me
personally no raising the sushi
um
I understand that we will come back to
council with the master plan and its
implications and then the direction from
that will establish the reserve
management plan and that's what we will
go out to the consultation to the
community on I'm just checking there for
Caroline is uh agreeing with that
position Carolyn
you're correct Steve yeah
right so the the mowing issue comes up
during the um management plan yeah
yeah mayor Clark did you think you just
want clarification stuff
um they have done barleys before though
haven't they
this is not something new
uh I'll refer that to Caroline
Matlock yes it's been veiled um for
several years out there sure yep okay
thank you thank you
uh look Mr Rowe thank you very much for
your interest on this issue and for
taking the time to come in and and speak
to us this afternoon
um obviously we'll make sure that you
and your users group are aware of when
the next time for consultation is
happening because obviously that's input
that we want but thank you very much for
your presentation today
thank you
counselors that moves us into the
minutes of the community wellbeing
committee back on May 23rd if somebody
wants to
move their confirmed Evelyn and Leslie
put that all in favor
I Against
carried uh minutes of the district
licensing committee meetings through May
happy to move those Leslie and Pete up
over sorry Tom
Peter
yeah on
and I find it
you go to number six other business and
you add at the end to the 4th of May
on the fourth bullet point it says
Speedway Riverside uh Reiki Park Subway
and members with reciprocal rights
Speedway I think the word should say a
really packed Speedway not Subway
correct
your sister
please feel free to free to email
through your spelling Corrections prior
to the meeting I just picked it up now
unless there's been a change
out there and they're serving some sort
of fast food thanks Peter we'll note
that Tom
I don't know if this is a question
really but the minutes cheer but I'll
make it anyway how exposed Derby to you
falling under the bus
uh not at all because there are three
other members of the committee okay
because just obviously your name that's
the so there are weekly meetings to sign
off uh licenses renewals and
applications the whole committee isn't
required for that they're done under
delegated authority the rest of the
committee is involved when their uh
policy issues to to be decided on all
hearings
okay thank you
good question though thank you
any others if not it's been moved and
seconded that I put there all in favor
and I'm just looking for a bus I'm
saying I I just carried
that brings us on to the activities
report
are there any issues here they will take
it as one if counselors have any issues
on
any areas of significance now is the
time to raise them
yeah maybe my ignorance but I but just
like some understanding around the
website figures that are on uh
on page 12 and 13.
and possibly I'm 14 as well
and your question
well the figures don't seem to line up
and and so when I look at these figures
um before I can sake the ones that are
on page 30.
it talks about what reaches and talks
about what engagement is but it doesn't
tell you what
um Park visit pace
what page visits are
and so I don't understand at the top of
the page where it says organic and paid
reach that in a month we've had a 13
000 hits
Lisa can you shed some light on the
differences between those terms things I
can uh there actually appears to be an
error in regards to the coloring of that
graph so where one is blue and one is
orange they should both be blue orange
for paid Rich would indicate if we had
paid for any Facebook advertising that
type of thing
um which if it would be added on top of
the number
if that makes sense
sorry can we just sorry can we wind back
so we're on page 14.
it's page 13 Woodworks
um can you explain the difference
between organic and paid reach
engagement and Page visits
so organic and paid reach regarding
Facebook organic is when we make a
Facebook post and it goes on our page it
goes to our followers and whatever's
Facebook's algorithm deems appropriate
at that time uh paid reach is if we pay
to promote a certain post or if we
list a Facebook ad through Facebook to a
targeted audience
uh the second part of your question
reach an engagement there is a
description underneath those graphs
um
uh on the second page for Facebook
and then page views on the website is
slightly different again and there's
also a description on those there as
well
does that help me Clark uh well a little
bit I guess but I mean what I'm trying
to understand is you know what sort of
reach I guess uh how websites have their
Facebook and and on the preceding page
on the website users page
so I guess on the previous page it
reasonably clear that
um
the number of unique visitors who enter
our website for a month is 25 000.
so that's really positive but then when
we get over Facebook it sort of says a
number of engagements is 3400.
but then it talks about pay visits about
being six thousand eight hundred so is
that implying that on average they look
at two pages when they're online
uh through you check great question
um so the Facebook engagement is people
that have connected with one of our
posts so when we post something it goes
on to everybody's news feed and if they
engage with it like it comment on it
that would be considered an engagement
the Facebook page visits is if people
have specifically visited the
invercargill city council Facebook page
uh searched it up clicked on it looked
at it scrolled down whatever they've
done with it
so one of one of those two figures
by the engagement or the page visits
must be underpinning the first set of
data that's on there which is the
organic and paid reach which is 113 000.
133 000.
so the organic and paid reach and let's
discount the word paid because there's
nothing being boosted
are the people who just simply scroll
past it
they've been saying that they've seen it
but they haven't interacted with it at
all they're walking past the shop window
yep it's a great way of describing it
around just the walk past the shop
window they've not gone in so my last
question just
so I understand it is the preceding
graph which talks about unique users is
the one that's the most important one
and that's telling us how many people
actually visited our website
regardless of how many pages they look
at so that that is implying 25 000. so
that's the city council's website and
yes okay
thank you
thanks good questions
any others
in the activities report sorry sorry
we've got another one on on the on we're
now on page 16. which is upcoming key
events
so a key event for this Saturday is the
uh flames on S Street
uh
sorry this is at the Civic Theater sorry
this is the Civic Theater
only a Civic Theater yep okay
but yes the Flames as a key event for
the Saturday and I'm just wondering why
we we
don't have that as part of our our Focus
what should just be on what's
so this is for our venues
I can respond to that through YouTube
um so that is a very recent event that's
only been promoted in the last week and
this report was written prior to that
being available and that is now promoted
um through
yeah sorry
the flying one yeah so that's now
promoted since we've had that
information available to us which has
been since the road closure was approved
thank you so just a final question to
that that last event that Flames an air
Street
um how are we promoting that given this
this coming Saturday so What mechanisms
are we using because that's uh one of
our inner city activators that we want
to really get on top of
so
um What mechanisms are we using if we're
not using our website
and we'll be using our website and their
social media but it's at our event Lisa
uh so it's not technically our event
Great South is running it and we're
supporting their promotion we've shared
it on our social media on uh our digital
screens that are in our facilities
um I believe also hopefully on our
website but I can check
thank you it's not there now it'll be
there later
sorry nobody will see something else
yeah there was actually
um just wanted to get a handle on the uh
the temporary pump track that's been
uh I use that there's a different
organizer I've helped the fundraise for
um
and so it says that over the next year
or so
um four confirmed locations Black Knight
caps New Field and Winton
I just wondered why South City wasn't
included in that
Russell Square would have been an ideal
this piece of land there would have been
an ideal place to put it
oh they do actually have a BMX track
Elizabeth yeah this is this is the pump
track though this much it's much younger
children
uh that's just the first year and I
think they'd sorted out four venues okay
active sales and promotion but um I'm
involved in one of the organizations
that lianges with them so happy to take
it to them and ask that question and the
very last one for me is on on the same
page again which is the Anzac Day
commemorations
um if somebody could help me about
um
we had a light show that uh
put both the poppies and the soldier up
onto the side of the senator do we know
who did that
on the day
back you know because it was really
positive I just yeah Carolina's that
something you can answer
it's here and now but I will get back to
my club yeah that'd be helpful to know
who did that
it's I mean it's simple projection
technology um it's cheap looks good
it was really impressive thank you
thanks
councilor Dermody yeah just with respect
to the building and planning the drop in
the code of compliance from 100 to 94.
is there
is it just a black or is it a trend
that's starting to develop around
you know not being able to get codes of
compliance completed so through you
chair I can assure you it's just a blip
right
it's good
Evelyn
uh yes Mr chair just in terms of on page
11 for books learn to swim and the
refugees that were brought in by Aurora
College do we not have a program in
conjunction with red cross to ensure
that refugees are offered learn to swim
that we've got to be dependent on Aurora
to do that for us
Steve I just was curious I I hadn't
occurred to me before uh three years ago
the team at the pool are working through
Red Cross and that was
um the way in which they wanted to
engage and so we've just enabled it
thank you for that because I I do see it
as a positive initiative
um so I applaud whoever's idea it was
thank you
now are the questions yep
just just to curriculum apparently it
ERD in seducing that flames on E Street
was actually on Saturday it's actually
Friday this week
and one other issue for me is on page 23
where it refers to the Southern Museum
and art gallery collection and it makes
some brief um reference to
um the Pacifica collection
and I've had to reach an approach from
George Nye about them potentially having
some of the collection down in their
area could you give us an update on that
the team have been working with
the through George and the team around
sharing some of the collection I think
that's um underway if not happened
thank you
movie to received the report
Tom and Grant
now for the questions I'll put that all
in favor
aye against
carried
they're being no further items in open
uh I'll move that we go into public
excluded to confirm the minutes of the
PE session from May 9th under Section
721 seconded councilor get put that all
in favor against Kerry to those who
joined us on the live stream